un lascaux sous les eaux en 1991 une
grotte est repéré entre marseille et
cassis à 37 mètres de profondeur un
plongeur a découvert son embouchure
il s'agit d' henri cosquer qui laissera
son nom en haut lieu
c'est là que j'ai découvert des chevaux
des chevaux peine des bizots chevret
servent des oiseaux la grotte cosquer
est une avancée pour l'archéologie comme
à lascaux ou achevés les parois sont
ornés de chevaux de bison mais parmi ses
oeuvres datant de 15 mille à dix mille
ans avant jésus-christ certaines
interpelle les spécialistes il ya peu
près 25 mai négative les grosses
surprises sont les animaux marais c'est
à dire il y a deux phoques et trois
pingouins et c'est la première fois en
europe qu'on a des pingouins est
représenté dans l'art l'art pariétal
affaires de préserver les lieux la
grotte cosquer a été classé aux
monuments historiques dès 1992 un
possible de la visiter
c'est un enseignement tiré de l'asco qui
a pâti de la présence humaine dans les
années 50
si on les ouvre et au public en les
détruire en détruire et le climat
ses peintures ne pourrait pas durer il
faut qu'on puisse les garder
rien ne sert de s'approcher depuis la
mère seule une cabane indique
l'emplacement de la grotte mais sous
l'eau l'accès est verrouillé ça paraît
bizarre
de tout ça on dessous
ok soit magnifique en revanche des
clichés de la grotte ont été présentées
lors d'une exposition en 1994 pour la
première fois au public à marseille en
2000 les parois de cosquer ont été
modélisés par ordinateur en réalité
virtuelle
ce travail nourri les recherches du cnrs
assisté par edf
les hommes préhistoriques ont peint en
épousant les formes de la grotte et en
relief cette incroyable ce qu'on peut
voir et ces bisons qui semble sortir des
parois c'est quelque chose qui dans
quelques années il sera même possible de
visiter la grotte cosquer ou de presque
une réplique sera construite à la vie la
méditerranée à marseille
accessible même lorsque l'original sera
gagnée par les autres
[Musique]